merci de nous rejoindre sur TVfil il est
temps de passer au 7 8 sports bonsoir
Anthony bonsoir Wilfrid bonsoir à tous
dans cette édition du 7 8 sport
évidemment tous les résultats du
week-end comme toutes les semaines nous
parlerons également de football
américain avec Georges Agostino qui nous
a rejoint le président des Templiers
d'Élancourt qui se sont qualifiés pour
les demi-finales du championnat de
France élite je reviendrai sur la
médaille de bronze ce week-end du
versaillais Thomas Barouk au championnat
d'Europe d'aviron et enfin du handisport
avec la troisième édition du triathlon
du haut de versa qui va se dérouler ce
samedi et donc l'actualité sportive ce
sont les Templiers qui la font cette
actualité sportive tout va bien pour le
Président vous avez quitté au moment de
la montée du retour parmi l'élite ça
s'était joué d'ailleurs sur tapis vert
et puis finalement tout se passe bien
puisqu'ils sont dans le dernier carré
oui vous êtes qualifié donc vous êtes 4e
après cette saison régulière d'ailleurs
je vous propose de jeter un petit un
petit coup d'oeil à ce classement après
cette saison hier voilà vous êtes
quatrième avec 22 points le flash de La
Courneuve les dauphins de Nice et les
Black Panthers de Thonon-les-Bains vous
précède euh le président au moins fort
que les dauphins voilà
c'est assez drôle les noms des équipes
comment vous choisissez le nom des
équipes oh je pense bah historiquement
bon ça vient des États-Unis tout les
clubs universités
on s'appelle comment
très très longtemps et vous êtes
satisfait alors de ce bilan après cette
saison il y a une quatrième place plutôt
une espérée ou attendue du club
l'objectif du club principal était le
pérenniser l'équipe en première division
donc de pas descendre de pas faire les
barrages on espérait gagner la moitié de
nos matchs donc 5 matchs au minimum bon
on en a gagné un de plus le sixième
match donc qui nous ouvre accès au
playoffs final donc on est jusque là
c'est parfait et alors ce premier match
de de phase finale 7 demi-finale va va
avoir lieu face au flash de La Courneuve
c'est un gros choc puisqu'ils ont
terminé en tête de la saison régulière
c'est c'était le pire adv attirer non
peut-être bah il fallait qu'on gagne à
Nice on devait gagner à Nice ce week-end
pour pour éventuellement recevoir
Thonon-les-Bains comme on a perdu donc
on va chez les meilleurs c'est non
seulement les meilleurs
au classement mais c'est aussi la
meilleure attaque et la meilleure
défense ils sont assez complexes donc
avec ça on va essayer de faire le
maximum et on va faire le maximum et il
y a rien de jouer sur un match bien sûr
que nous on y va on y va confiant et
alors cette saison cette qualification
vous la devez peut-être à votre début de
saison en fait qui a été tonitruant
puisque 5 victoires en 5 matchs sur les
les premières journées c'est c'est
plutôt exceptionnel déjà ce bilan de
première partie qu'est-ce qui nous a mis
en pôle position là pour les pour les
phases finales bon on a démarré par un
très bon match à Amiens on a battu les
champions de France en titre chez eux on
s'est dit c'est déjà un peu la surface
déjà un peu la grosse surprise pourquoi
pas continuer et puis on a continué
après malheureusement bon il y a
quelques blessures
de starter ce qu'on appelle chez nous de
titulaire
qui sont arrivés les jeunes après les
autres on a c’était un peu plus
compliqué structurellement à maintenir
ce rythme ça aurait été de toute façon
inespéré de gagner tous nos matchs mais
voilà justement le groupe c'est un peu
essoufflé et avec l'accumulation des
blessures la dynamique est devenue un
peu plus négative
dynamique négative à partir de la 6e du
6e match et première des fêtes bon on
était sur le bas dynamique et
effectivement donc les blessures les
backup les remplaçants qui étaient
peut-être pas tout à fait tout à fait
prêt parce qu'on savait qu'on avait que
des matchs pièges et puis peut-être que
dans la tête on se croyait peut-être un
peu trop beau peut-être trop beau
peut-être aussi moi tout ça fait que
qu'on enchaîné trois victoires à trois
défaites
après encore contre Amiens chez nous un
petit point un petit point donc le
ticket pour la finale donc voilà bah
maintenant on récupère la semaine
prochaine on récupère quelques blessés
on espère savoir aller mieux on n'est
pas encore tout on sera pas à 100% c'est
sûr quand les défaites ont commencé à
revenir ou n'avait pas été inquiets à
aucun moment où vous êtes dit la spirale
est pas bonne malheureusement qu'on
avait c'est ça qui m'a fait ça que
Victor auparavant donc ça nous a un peu
rassuré on savait on essaie la capacité
de l'équipe quoi donc ça nous a un peu
rassuré de ce côté-là on avait un match
piège c'était effectivement contre
Amiens et on les a battus un petit point
certes moins abattu quand même puis
voilà et puis après les autres matchs
parfois ça commence parfois ça quoi et
ce dernier match là donc vous perdez du
côté de Nice ce week-end face au dauphin
21.7 ça laisse un goût amer avant la
préparation justement ça entache un peu
cette préparation pour les playoffs non
du tout parce que bon on va pas rentrer
dans la rencontre il y a beaucoup
d'entraîneurs de qui disent que on met à
des pas de perdre même si le score est
voilà on a eu d'autres temps de refuser
pour diverses raisons
la faute des arbitres
non plus mais c'est pas je me disais
aussi
célébration excessive etc et
sur les trois blessés on en récupère
deux ce week-end donc voilà c'est pas
mal à s'intégrer justement la barrière
de la langue etc ça a été ça pas été
trop compliqué parce que dès le premier
match on était là à domicile il avait
déjà cartonné comme on dit et il a l'air
de vraiment s'être intégré très vite la
langue c'est quelque chose de logique on
a des Américains on importe en apporte
des Américains tous les trois quarts
d'équipe par l'américain il y a pas il y
a pas de problème on a de traducteurs
qui peuvent traduire pour les autres non
non on a qu'un problème lui c'est
effectivement
c'est intégré très très vite très très
vite c'est vrai qu'il est arrivé trois
semaines un mois avant le 1er match on a
vu tout de suite qui était prêt
normalement les Américains enfin mais
comme il avait joué en Europe donc je
reviens pas voilà
on prend toujours on essaie de prendre
des Américains disponibles qui ont déjà
une espérance européenne ce qui fait et
alors pour revenir sur ces demi-finales
qui approchent un c'est ce weekend là
vous allez vous déplacer à La Courneuve
est-ce que il va falloir justement
éviter les des erreurs que vous avez
commises justement pendant cette pendant
cette saison régulière
à votre avis pour voilà se donner une
chance du côté de moi la chance disons
que son niveau sportif là on a rencontré
la Courneuve on a perdu certes ça fait
partie des trois défaites de suite on a
perdu contre La Courneuve mais on savait
que on était on était pas trop loin il
nous manquait énormément de baissé donc
là on a récupéré un petit peu ça nous
fera du bien
ça maintenant c'est les entraîneurs de
préparer tout ça je crois qu'ils sont en
train d'être portugais c'est pour ça que
Charlène elle va punir ce soir ils sont
en train de préparer déjà à demi-finale
non non on a moyen on va dire c'est du
60-40 60 pour eux 40 pour nous ils sont
très concentrés déjà les joueurs avec
Emmanuel Charet justement ancien soin
ancien joueur
on a parlé ce weekend du long voyage à
Nice donc on attend de se parler non non
effectivement ils savent qu'ils ont une
bonne carte à jouer là très bien du côté
de La Courneuve ce week-end 7
demi-finale face au flash Ostende
Marville donc il y a de la place il y a
des milliers de 1000 personnes
les croiser et long courtois merci à
vous merci Anthony on continue avec du
sport c'est aussi une balle mais plus
petite elle va très vite aussi c'est du
tennis depuis plus d'une semaine vous
l'avez remarqué le tournoi de
Roland-Garros ça a ouvert ses portes sur
cette édition 2013 nous sommes
intéressés à Thomas Moulis un jeune
joueur plaisir roi en devenir qui
côtoient au plus près Rogers Federer et
les autres car il est ramasseur de
balles Porte d'Auteuil nous l'avons
suivi dans les allées de Roland Garros
avec Patrick Jacques delixmude
son tournoi de Roland-Garros à lui ne
pouvait pas mieux débuter dès le premier
jour le plaisir watte au mamounir
ramasse les balles du match de Roger
Federer il va transpirer pendant deux
semaines sur les cours sans jamais
toucher une raquette apprendre à être
invisible aux yeux des joueurs et le
comble dans tout ça il n'a même pas le
droit d'applaudir à la fin des points on
n'a pas toujours cette chance mais c'est
vraiment c'est magique c'est
vraiment énorme surtout quand on est sur
le central ça c'est impressionnant alors
que des fois on est sur des petits
courbes on simplement
Thomas n'avait pas été sélectionné lors
de sa première candidature habituée des
tribunes par le passé désormais au bord
du filet ce jeune joueur se rend compte
de l'importance des ramasseurs
normalement vient toutes les années mais
c'est vrai que je faisais jamais très
attention au ramasseur on les voit pas
trop faudra que c'est génial quand même
mettre sur le coup
ce jour-là le jeune plaisir roi est
affecté au cours numéro 6 avec un
premier match du tableau féminin pour
débuter avant chaque entrée sur le
terrain l'échauffement se fait dans les
allées au milieu même des spectateurs
son évaluateur ne t'en permanence la
qualité de son ramassage être
sélectionné pour le tournoi du Grand
Chelem ne suffit pas il faut faire
partie des meilleurs pour officier sur
le court central
les critères c'est va tout d'abord les
rouler c'est une chose importante c'est
la transmission entre deux ramasseurs
donc on demande à rouler plat rapide ça
demande de la vitesse aussi de
coordination et aussi de l'anticipation
et de la concentration au maximum sur le
terrain et il a fait une rotation très
correcte avec une autre paire de filets
donc après on verra au fur et au fur et
à mesure de la journée parce que eux ils
sont trois paires du filet donc du coup
ça tourne un petit peu moins que les
fonds mais après c'est à lui de se
donner à fond pour pouvoir passer sur le
cours de transition demain quoi le jeune
hyblinois passe environ 3h30 par jour
sur le terrain pendant tout le tournoi
il est dispensé d'école mais n'oublie
pas c'est de voir pour autant car il
reste les pieds sur terre et c'est qu'il
ne pourra pas devenir joueur
professionnel il rêve désormais de
partager le cours avec Raphaël Nadal
peut-être lors de la finale le 9 juin
prochain
nous allons changer d'éléments Wilfried
de la terre battu à au plan d'eau et à
l'aviron précisément puisque ce week-end
avait lieu les championnats d'Europe
d'avion du côté de Séville et évidemment
nous suivons la saison de Thomas Barouk
le rameur de Versailles du Cercle
Nautique de Versailles qui a récolté une
très belle médaille de bronze aux 400
barreurs poids léger ce week-end en
Espagne et il est avec nous en direct
justement Thomas bonsoir Thomas
alors je crois qu'il y a qu'un seul mot
c'est félicitations pour cette belle
médaille non
merci beaucoup vous êtes plutôt
satisfait de votre niveau sur ces
championnats d'Europe
oui très satisfait même en fait c'était
une première sortie de l'année donc on
cherche un peu des repères entre nous et
puis on avait peu de d'informations sur
les autres bateaux
donc oui très très satisfait c'est pas
sorti et alors par rapport à votre
niveau à vous personnel on vous avait
suivi cet hiver il y avait eu beaucoup
de blessures qui vous avez handicapé
c'est un peu une médaille inespérée
justement par rapport à ce retour en
forme
inespéré peut-être pas parce que j'ai
quand même beaucoup travaillé pour
revenir à ce niveau là mais en tout cas
ouais ça vient récompensé tout le
travail qui a été fait et justement ça a
été dur de rattraper le ballotard de cet
hiver vous avez loupé beaucoup
d'entraînement
encore au niveau que j'espère et
attendre mais en tout cas voilà
la médaille d'or sur ces championnats
d'Europe était inaccessibles pour
l'équipe de France sur cette sur ce 400
barreur
il nous reste encore beaucoup de travail
pour atteindre le niveau des Danois qui
ont gagné
mais rien n'est impossible on a on a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire parce
que le bateau est un peu d'expérience et
peu de travail ensemble donc c'est une
bonne augure pour la suite et alors
votre votre époque blessure entre
guillemets à répétition et révolu ça y
est là vous êtes vous êtes complètement
guéri il y a plus de bobos comme on dit
et ben pour l'instant tout va bien
pourvu que ça dure j'espère avoir épuisé
mon quota de blessure pour les quatre
ans à venir elle pourrait être
tranquille maintenant et alors par
rapport à l'équipage vous en avez dit un
petit mot vous vous étiez pas beaucoup
entraîné ensemble c'est un équipage qui
est jaune entre guillemets au niveau de
l'Union voilà il y a encore beaucoup de
potentiel de progression derrière
ouais vraiment il y a énormément de
potentiel on a très très peu ramené
ensemble on a fait une petite centaine
de kilomètres ensemble alors que les
autres bateaux en face sont plusieurs
milliers on va dire de kilomètres
ensemble
donc oui on a encore beaucoup de choses
à gagner sur la notre technique
individuelle notre niveau physique et
peut-être pas encore totalement à son
maximum puisque c'est pas le saison on
est le plus en forme et puis ensuite en
termes de cohésion et d'expérience dans
des conditions difficiles dans des
conditions de compétition on a encore
beaucoup gagné et alors avec cette
médaille de bronze au championnats
d'Europe vous êtes qualifié pour les
championnats du monde fin août ou il
faut encore obtenir ce ticket
et complètement décédé ça semble bien
parti je pense que cette médaille
rassure tout le monde et montre bien le
potentiel de cet équipage
il reste encore une étape de coupe du
monde
mi-juillet avant de d'aller au
championnat du monde mais en tout cas ça
sent bon très bien merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à vos questions Thomas et puis
encore félicitations pour cette belle
médaille de bronze en suivant donc la
suite de la saison merci à lui et
félicitations